not every mcu character gets their own
movie it just seems like it still there
are tons of cool supporting characters
who deserve the spotlight just as much
as their more celebrated compatriots
here's a look at the most underrated
characters in the mcu
originally a shield agent james jimmy wu
was recruited by the fbi before
eventually serving as scott lang's
parole officer in 2018's ant-man and the
wasp wu strongly suspects lange is
breaking his parole and indeed he is
although he always manages to cover it
up regardless wu tries to catch him as
well as hank pym and hope van dyne for
violating the terms of the scovia courts
but can't quite manage it years later as
seen in one division wu is instrumental
in unraveling the mystery of westview
which has been besieged by wanda
maximoff's reality warping powers wu was
such a favorite in one division that
fans have been clamoring for a spin-off
jimmy wu solo series but so far no word
from marvel if such a thing will ever
materialize
if you're looking for definitive proof
that andy serkis best known for playing
gollum in the lord of the rings and
hobbit trilogies and caesar and the
planet of the apes franchise can do more
than just motion capture look no further
than his performance as the evil ulysses
claw a black market arms dealer who
appears in 2015's avengers age of ultron
and 2018's black panther circus steals
every scene he's in with his portrayal
of claw's offbeat sense of humor claw is
downright giddy while battling black
panther and he's equally excited about
giving out copies of his mixtape
unfortunately for claw and for fans
killmonger betrays and kills him before
his own plan fails at the hands of
t'challa circus just brings so much
chilling lunatic energy to his
performance that we have to give him his
due can someone give this man an oscar
already it's quite
the entourage you got a mixtape coming
out oh yeah yeah actually there is one
yeah i'll send you the soundcloud link
if you like it's weird that we meet
mantis a naively sweet mind-reading
alien empath as the personal assistant
to a genocidal maniac but the more you
get to know her the more you realize she
probably didn't know any better all her
interactions are colored by her
perpetual state of innocent confusion
like certain other members of the
guardians of the galaxy she doesn't
really get subtlety nuance or the
intricacies of metaphor people usually
want cute pets
why would you go on such a hideous one
i am hideous you are horrifying to look
at yes
beyond her oblivious nature mantis is
impressively powerful and ends up
becoming a major asset in the fight
against thanos she even puts the big
purple bad guy himself into a trance
while other avengers hold him down she's
certainly not the most important avenger
or even the most important guardian but
actor pom clementiev makes mantis so
much fun and memorable that we had to
put her on this list
much praise has been given to florence
pugh's performance as elena bulova
natasha romanov's sister in 2021's black
widow there's a reason for that she's
excellent comparatively less praise has
been directed towards their father
figure however david harbor's hilarious
and obtuse red guardian red guardian was
a cold war era soviet spy who was
injected with super soldier serum to
compete with the us's own captain
america he claims the two fought in
their heyday but as another inmate
points out cap was under the ice when
alexi says this happened the issue is
raised again but never properly resolved
and answers are in short supply but
answers are also beside the point harbor
is an absolute delight to watch in every
scene he's in and we hope we see more of
this character sooner rather than later
while ronan the accuser has bad guy
written all over him the guardians of
the galaxy's second major villain ego
initially comes off as a pretty nice guy
after all he is peter quill's dad the
godlike planet-owning celestial is just
thrilled to see his son and rope him
into the family business which is let us
check our notes here oh yeah right
killing all life and absorbing it into
himself
yikes there seems to have been a lot of
that going around the mcu at the time
naturally quill and the guardians have
to take him down it's no easy task and
they suffer some heartbreak along the
way but they get it done that being said
kurt russell is simply great in this
villainous one-off role even when he's
describing what it's like to be a lonely
god or his genocidal intentions he comes
off as a good old-fashioned dad who just
wants to include his son in a project
it's a great performance that elevates
the film in 2016's doctor strange
benedict wong's performance as wong is
easily one of the best and funniest
parts of the movie though he's a
supporting character he is also a master
of the mystic arts in his own right he's
funny quick-witted and very very good at
what he does as thanos goons find out
the hard way in 2018's avengers infinity
war and 2019's avengers end game we
didn't get to see nearly enough of wong
which is why it's exciting that he's
poised to make more appearances in phase
4 as doctor strange and the multiverse
take center stage we can't wait
played inimitably by kat denning's darcy
lewis is a bit of a stand-in for the
audience she's by jane foster and eric
selvig's side when thor crash lands on
earth and while they take these
outrageous extraterrestrial events in
stride she's always around to
hilariously remind them that no this is
not normal her quips provide some of the
best parts of 2011's thor but other than
a minor appearance in 2013's thor dark
world we haven't seen her again on the
big screen luckily she made a triumphant
return to the mcu in one division in
this series she's finally gotten her
doctorate in astrophysics and is
instrumental in unraveling the mysteries
of westview a town trapped by the
sitcom-centric magic of one wanda
maximoff it's a story rooted in profound
grief but cat denix always brings some
much-needed quirky humor to the table
when she's on screen hopefully we
haven't seen the last of her thor's
galaxy spanning universe saving
adventures are the stuff of legend and
for good reason but his good buddy
heimdall played as epically as you'd
expect by idris elba is just as much of
a hero his is a lonely job which
undoubtedly involves hours or days if
not longer standing in a lonely chamber
waiting for a call but without him
asgard would be cut off from the outside
world and the universe would be a much
more dangerous place because of it in
thor ragnarok heimdall gets his chance
to shine leading as guardian refugees
into the mountains to escape hela's
murderous forces when they're escaping
on the bridge he defends his people
again and is instrumental in helping
them escape as the place is destroyed
behind them sadly he never does get the
credit he's due dying unceremoniously at
the hands of thanos but
not before using the last of his magic
to transport hulk to earth and since
it's hulk who ultimately uses the
infinity gauntlet to restore the
universe you can't overstate heimdall's
importance to the mcu it's a shame this
gem of a character is buried in the
ant-man movies likely the most
under-appreciated entries in the mcu he
is without a doubt one of the funniest
characters in the franchise played by
michael pena luis meets scott lang in
prison after getting out scott becomes
ant-man and luis is right by his side
supporting him in the background in
2018's ant-man and the wasp luis and
some other prison buddies trying to make
a living with felonies on their record
start ex-con security consultants heck
even in avengers end game luis's van is
instrumental to the avengers time
traveling exploits in every appearance
pena plays luis as a rapid-fire motor
mouth with a heart of gold and a
penchant for boring people with
long-winded monologues that have little
to do with the subject at hand he also
never seems to truly grasp what's going
on but always manages to pull through
for his buddy scott ant-man and all his
friends survive the events of avengers
endgame so here's hoping we'll get to
see more pena in this role
we didn't know what to think when we
first saw valkyrie in thor ragnarok she
is a stumbling drunk who saves a
hammerless thor from scavengers only to
kidnap him and sell him into slavery as
thor eventually discovers she used to be
a powerful asgardian warrior who was
defeated by hela and now drinks herself
into a nightly stupor but then she has
her redemption she joins thor and bruce
banner on their trip back to asgard to
fight hella and after the asgardian
refugees are decimated by thanos she
helps them settle on earth in avengers
endgame after battling thanos in the
final battle thor appoints her ruler of
the asgardian people it's a great
character arc all we can say is long
live the queen
this minor dorky bad guy from 2010's
iron man 2 almost never gets talked
about we kind of get it he's primarily
used for comic relief in one of the
franchise's most overlooked movies in
the broader scheme of things he only
plays a small role in james rhodes
acquiring the war machine suit but his
larger narrative insignificance doesn't
matter sam rockwell's performance as
this nerdy ankle-biting corporate
competitor to the vastly cooler and
smarter tony stark is too delightful not
to mention here every line of dialogue
he delivers is dripping with cringy dead
humor-ish sleaze whether he's at the
senate hearing meeting whiplash selling
guns to the military or doing his
unforgettably goofy dance at the expo
he's always pitch perfect sadly we
haven't really seen the characters since
other than a cameo in the all hail the
king short so come on marvel we don't
care what you have to do just bring back
rockwell's hammer
from pepper potts to peter parker to
james rhodes tony stark has no shortage
of allies but his dependable fiercely
loyal old pal former chauffeur and stark
industries security chief happy hogan
played delightfully by mcu architect
john favreau deserves a mention here
simply put he's just so much fun to
watch when tony is being tony happy's
always around to reign in his excesses
and keep him focused when iron man is
off saving the world happy can be found
on the ground working tirelessly to
protect everything his boss holds dear
and after key roles in everything from
iron man 2 to avengers end game he's
gone on to become an important part of
the spider-man film franchises as well
as mentor to peter parker happy hogan
might be a comic relief character before
he's anything else but his support of
iron man and spidey makes all the
difference we'd all be lucky to have
such a true friend by our sides
where's parker
it's with a girl i need to speak with
him
he'll call you a vicious cyborg warrior
and thanos's younger daughter nebula
takes out her rage on her battlefield
foes in the first guardians of the
galaxy film she makes killing gamora her
elder sister a priority in the hopes
that their abusive father will approve
and recognize her abilities but she
never manages to pull it off much to her
fury nebula is no match for gamora and
her new friends and she's soon captured
by the guardians and held against her
will while in their custody though she
has a change of heart and in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 she ultimately sides
with them against ego and eventually her
own father nebula fights thanos on titan
before becoming an instrumental
participant in the time travel plot
central to avengers endgame she even
runs into her past self and is forced to
kill her to save her friends it's an
incredible story brought to life by
karen gillan's powerful performance over
the course of multiple movies that star
other people both inside and outside the
mcu nebula never seems to get the
respect she clearly deserves but it's
time that changes here's to many more
mcu movies featuring our favorite blue
mini
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you